citizens of the reject Nation we are
diving into Batman versus Robin and
spoiler alert much like these other
movies John and I haven't seen it nope
nope not well once koi this will be a
fresh experience and I'm very excited uh
first time watching any of these movies
but also a first even in this series and
that we think this is the first one
that's actually a one to one yeah Throne
of Atlantis goes right into Batman vs
Robin for the first time yeah yeah we
will finally have like a direct
continuation installment in tandem which
is amazing chronologically and
emotionally it's about to go down so
please do leave a like leave a comment
hit that subscription Bell let us know
which of these you've enjoyed most let
us know which you want in your wonky
order to be watched next because I
personally I watch Fast and Furious one
two I save Tokyo Drift for after we meet
Han because he dies in that movie and
then he comes back everybody's got their
own order let us know what you'd watch
next we're gonna watch it
chronologically let us know in the
comments also please share this with
your friends we have a blast doing these
but they can only work if they grow but
remember if you want to sync this up
Line to Line sync to sync face to face
and watch our resting faces ready
then become a very sexy Patron and you
can watch this entire Journey with us as
we go through it but either way let's
get into Batman versus Robin
[Music]
it's James Gunn's favorite James guns
this is the movie they're adapting
it's actually blinding
Ichabod Crane I'd half a mind to report
you for Grand Theft Auto
oh Damien good driver I called and told
you to meet me up here didn't I well
what did the town that was wiped out by
floods three years ago have to do with
the children that have gone missing and
got them
oh we're about to find out I found it a
little odd that every one of them owned
toys made here
if Damien an alternate response might be
good work Robin but I guess I expect too
much I'm still a mile out don't do
anything till I get there word of Honor
I won't do anything
uh right trust you as far as I can throw
you a kid he's pretty small
[Laughter]
had to beat dolls
I bet Harrison Ford loves these movies
remember Robin Justice not vengeance
Justice it's a pretty long mile for the
mountain that's like a minute um what
was this could have said 10 miles
in prison 12 years ago by the testimony
of his son and primary victim Anton the
son eventually took over the business
did a damn good job of it until the
floods came
[Music]
all right your specialty
you're worried about the little ones
is this an ice facility
this is aged up don't be
ice employee
oh I love them
more than you could ever know ew Anton's
shot died when he was a little boy I am
the doll maker oh he's even got a creepy
ass doll hair
I've done everything in my power to help
the little ones survive
oh no
this is like a haunted house I went to
this is terrifying here yo
y'all protect me children as I protected
you
I mean you're way bigger than all of
them Jess
the nubby arm of a kid oh God
wow mutilated children in the opening
act with it wow
this is why Pattinson's Batman has to
stay separate from the Justice League
sure so you can do these stories yeah
exactly he was flying and it was a mile
out what were you doing yeah man well
you're a power saver my response might
be thanks Batman but I guess I expect
too much
it's a good Tyrone see that's the that's
the different Justice League Batman
we're gonna get it's gonna be great
Robin no it's just chucking kids
nice shot
hmm
I know it was the gas but it still looks
like it just knocked out
with abnormalities and oh no
you're safe now
I swear to you
swear to me
sorry I do like them showing the side of
Batman where he's actually like taking
the time to help the kids versus Chase
like yeah yeah we often see Batman just
being Vengeance nah Damien's got that
covered he's Vengeance some had to
sacrifice so that the others could live
sounds like Weird Al that's what he's
been up to that's dolls no one can ever
hurt them again no one can you want to
know about helplessness
let me teach you
damn shot come on now
have some dignity
go out like a tall man yeah fight him or
pull off one of your arms and beat him
with it
that Angelica hair shut up damn you or
I'll tear your heart out I'll tear it
out
he's learned he's learned
I'm just gonna terrify you with an image
of your life not Vengeance yay
oh
what oh whoa
oh don't doubt your instincts
is that a Talon yeah thanks I think so
what have you done
it what it's the world's greatest
detective that's not the man you know a
knife didn't do that a battery you also
know a child couldn't Fist Punch through
someone minimum I could have done it
easily but I didn't out of respect for
you out of respect for your [__] ass
did it
okay he does figure it out for yourself
okay I was really worried the impetus of
the verses was going to be Batman being
a bad detective and I was gonna be very
upset
it's the only way you can get Batman in
a conflict is you gotta you know dumb
down at all times otherwise he's just
too good Superman but his brain instead
of too much op it's the thinking they
could have easily had Talon stage it
where he used a batarang in order to
frame Robin if they want to go that
story sure but I'm glad they didn't make
that the villain would have been yeah
he's got his feather the game is on the
game is a foot there's a foot you cook
you clean you run the household I'm
impressed you should have seen me in my
days upon the stage Miss vanova and my
full staff was even better than my
cocovar that was a very serious child
unlike the zany mad cap you are now
Alfred's the only one who could ever get
me to laugh after three months together
I like to think I can too
but you're not as funny as Alfred
there's something I want to show
your bedroom all that
it's still early
three months is a very weird spot for
either of those mentions yet again one
way or the other it took you three
months but you finally made me laugh
I also love that she complimented Alfred
for doing his damn job
[Laughter]
rather than focus on the demons on the
darkness and all that's wrong with
Gotham it's time it's time to focus on
how exceptional this city is Damian
making him lighter it's gonna be really
cool in the movie but before we can
build it we have to dream it cool
[Laughter]
and who might this be
I'm Damien Bruce's my ward
we've been keeping me a secret only
until the paperwork is finalized then
we'll proudly announce the newest
addition to our family
you're taking this unfortunate child and
give them a chance at a better life you
have to do it your way he can
please don't tell me she's an owl what
an uncomfortable thing to say to a human
being this unfortunate child grabs face
no you should go we'll have other nights
I look forward to them hmm
I'm with you Damien I don't trust her do
I do like they brought a little the Val
Kilmer Bruce's philanthropy I do I do
appreciate she's very attractive
it's now why'd you say that name
you ever see the 1948 movie version
directed by David lean Rachel ghoul
wasn't much of a movie buff
I would love to see race uncle's movie
collection in the pit just watch it like
a hot tub
bubbles going popcorn trench and butter
and open up the screening room dude I
bet Alfred makes a mean popcorn oh man
uses like the coconut oil instead so it
pops a little better yeah some Himalayan
sea salt this is cute I like this one so
far a lot I like paternal Bruce yeah it
actually translates a little better in
the movies than the comics so far like I
don't know the voice acting like there's
a paternalness that doesn't quite read
in the frames I believe that
oh
interesting
I take it this is post movie night
or did he just like pieces I gotta pee
that's a lot better
I thought we were making some progress
you show me a movie and that gives you
permission to be a prisoner in my own
house bad enough you won't let me out in
public as Damien the least you could do
is let Robin have a life
you if you're a little more trustworthy
I would
never trusted me trust has to be earned
Damien that works both ways
big turtleneck family the Wayne's they
own stock in it
turtlenecks in the closet yeah
I mean I get it they're nice it's like
Doug
I'm sorry about sneaking out the other
night
and the night before that not so much
where are you going
what about me
I got you a sitter
oh if it's the girlfriend
it's Superman
[Laughter]
oh
yes oh always a good comment always
happy when Nightwing shows up every time
my grandfather taught me everything I
need to know about personal combat
and every time they met he kicked Ray
Charles
yeah trickles down it's got a point
there yeah
whoa
come on
she's watching a child in the face
your ass a beagle aren't you the pure
and perfect Dick Grayson oh I like this
yeah
yeah but I'm seeing I was the only rock
you're just so lost no Tim Drake in this
universe
sit your ass down
history of War geez Gotham's a dark
place sure they just they only show what
they know this is a light day out
beware the court of owls that watches
all the time take care beware or they
will send a town for your head
is it true dad is there really a secret
group of rich and powerful men who send
their talent out to destroy anyone who
dares to even mention their existence
it's a very specific way to ask that
question it's very bold parenting there
Thomas Wayne it's just a story Bruce
there's no court of owls that's why he
was so scared in that alley I know
you're explaining so much of his
backstory
your mother and I will always be here
[Music]
so are the owls involved is Joe Chill an
owl yeah it's always interesting how
they modify the the origin specifically
to like be ambiguous enough to be all
villains everyone's responsible oh an
actual hell is on the case yeah I do
love the imagery The Owl and the bat and
like Scott Snyder's Arc wasn't that long
ago for how much it's influenced like
it's done a lot yeah I think
cordobello's only like 10 15 years old I
was I was surprised to find that when I
saw the comic out yeah
[Music]
it's beautiful art oh I love Scott
Snyder's run him and Tom King are like
the foundation for me of modern Batman
spy
thank you
wow I was just chilling his house you
know he was in his own nest that was
just a regular owl most likely Damien
wave
I thought it was the court that killed
them
oh it's a little baby Bruce dang that's
that's cool actually that Vengeance
running in the family I knew that Harbor
House was the corpse headquarters I
watched them the richest men in Gotham
the most powerful little detective yeah
that's cool because that way it's not
necessarily the cause of death but he as
a child would infer Dad was right
it was
just a story
good
but not just a story oh damn boot blades
that's natural predator with Talons yeah
[Music]
oh with a sigh too
oh
[Music]
my God
oh cool
damn
you can maybe use your your ward
[Music]
the Ultimate Weapon
thanks
yeah get out of there Batman it's got
jacked up yeah he really got jacked up
oh
no that's a dinosaur that's why it's in
the cave now it's broken I had to put it
back together at home and take it home
and fix this
[Music]
damn yeah serious sometimes master Bruce
terrible things just happen they just
happen
oh I like that yeah cause it's like he's
not wrong right but at the same time
that's kind of the lesson life is
sometimes coincidence sometimes fate
stop
stop no I'm not kidding
you're wearing what
this is gonna bust a blood vessel
Master dick it's it's Batman in
C no you're Alfred don't lie very
confusing
please don't hurt him
you bastard
how about a dance old lady oh golly
[Music]
dcau's dark get him Damien
we give up
no who said surrender was an option
Jeeps
men like this don't deserve to live I
won't finish it for you this time the
decision has to be yours that voice my
name is Talon
come on
oh
he is prone to cult-like mentalities
yeah very recruitable what is this place
oh nice my respect for Batman and all
he's achieved is high
but there are lines he won't cross
perhaps out of fear
or some misguided moral code
it's that one he talks about it a lot
eradicate crime and criminals once and
for all
damn
I want you to join me when you've made
your decision use this to contact me
don't tell him about me I want to be
surprised where the hell were you out
that's mine I don't think so there's a
school in Switzerland run by a retired
General who knows far more than I do
about boys and discipline
huh Joey have you ever been in a Turkish
prison try this again that's where
you'll be spending the next year I mean
will they be able to keep him in there
it's in Switzerland Maybe
I think that was 1939 the year Batman
was invented hey running a little late
Samantha but I should be there in about
15 minutes I'm not a woman who likes
being kept waiting Bruce I'll do
everything in my power to make sure your
patience is
hahaha
[Music]
it's kind of giving me Matrix Reloaded
Vibes yeah see like I think Court of
owls would work in Pattinson but
wouldn't work in Justice League like I
feel like the Justice League would just
be like nope but like Patterson yeah
Superman just rip the roof off yeah
yeah yeah but in in a grounded like I
love the idea of tying it to that
government stuff that Thomas Wayne was
in in the first one and everything like
yeah make it part of the Hope how deep
do the roots go secret society
like now would be a great time for like
Mr Freeze and the owls as like a two
movie thing like Mr Freeze and this one
building to owls in three that'll be
right because you plant the seeds and
like
oh the Aston Martin
what the hell is this
an opportunity
and one you should be extremely grateful
for
do not miss your chance to blow
comes once in a lifetime you
who are you
the Grand Master of the court of owls a
faction Rose against us that even our
talents couldn't stop we were forced to
retreat oh we know far better than the
rabble what's best for our city we have
a vision of Gotham's future Mr Wayne
and so we understand
do you oh
Samantha How Could You scanned it with
her necklace or something
[Music]
invite you to join your vision to the
courts
together we can raise Gotham City up oh
cool cool shot
I can't say I'm not intrigued by the
offer
but I'd like some time to think it over
of course Mr way hey
it's okay you can use the road
vibrations to figure out exactly where
you came from smell the road
busted
[Music]
leave them in the oh that's great yeah
solid movement
eyes wide bat
or I guess Al's Wide Shut owl's white
shot sound like that's good work daddy
score Bruce Wayne is one of us
one of us one of us how is it going with
the boy
he's taking the bait
oh
bait
some of these Warriors are over a
hundred years old you saw what happened
to the talons at the Museum they
survived outside the caskets for more
than eight hours
and I envy each one of those hours we've
refined the resurrection process
immortality but only 24 hours at a time
after I undergo the ritual that will
make me like them a great Destiny awaits
you and I know you will willingly
embrace it it doesn't look like that
great of a destiny absolutely pretty
goopy you're gonna be a God that we need
to revive every single day and do a lot
of maintenance on grow scars very goopy
he never saw it coming I was 23 years
old and with those four shots I oh by
the time I was 30 I taken half the city
and let me tell you big Frankie he had
brains
all over the room
crime jokes it's good it's a good one
who the hell are you on the evening's
entertainment uh we are tonight's
Saturday
he's gonna show him a magic trick but
those
I can pay you more money than you've
ever seen
would I care about him payback for the
lives your drugs and ruined for the
widows of Orphans left in your bloody
wait oh finishing
we found enough evidence to put him away
for the rest of his life
he's already finished
man's Brett not anymore
oh now that's gonna go over with Talon I
had a bad
man I was his shadow dang
cat man
no matter what I did how hard I tried oh
dude
but what could I do
huh
oh
in a blaze of glory I was recruited by a
secret society the court of owls gave me
strength and purpose what they did for
me I want to do for you
he's using you Robin to get to me well
for your information he sees something
in me that you don't I don't have time
for this
the choice you make tonight will Define
you for the rest of your life
[Music]
I mean he did like dismiss him 10 times
in a row I mean not the best parent in
there Bruce true
[Music]
switch to offense
using the cape against ah I was gonna
say I liked how much he was blocking at
the start but at the beginning of the
defense it's gone now jeez
[Music]
oh man
you are grounded that is Batman and
right there
wow
literally kicking him against gravity oh
protect him oh
he literally protected you on the way
down this is what you want then do it
free me
no he killed Batman no that's it there
it is there it is there's the shot
now let's go home my home isn't with you
it never was
I like that Bruce thinks that's
parenting Yep this is how we solve
problems that Wayne Manor
you know just fall off the building you
know you get it all out it's the Wayne
Manor Manor
this is good it is oh that's how we do
our word is law
since when do you believe in the law
only one law my love
my law
some weird Pillow Talk lady yeah where's
my man Grundy I want a Solomon Grundy
comes at a point
no your transmission is breaking up
[Music]
been waiting for you you were watching
me in the tunnels we have eyes across
Gotham observing and recording your
everywhere those ancient sewers have
been flooded with an odorless
psychotropic Gap
all noise at the roots of the Mind
twisting and winding until it resembles
nothing so much as a labyrinth oh you
don't got scarecrow
experiencing bad ego death oh he's gonna
wake up way better but it's gonna be a
rough night yep
trust us Bruce it gets better
oh
God even animated that still hurts man
it's going for the eye I'll find my way
through this and I'll bring this whole
damn Court crashing down around you
around your [__] oh no Crime Alley
[Music]
oh
but don't hurt my family please no
wow
when you put on that mask you became one
with the very forces that killed your
parents you respond to the greatest
monster Gotham City has ever seen the
epilogue from zsjl Jared let us come out
and quote some internet memes we live in
a society
Damien no
oh
[Music]
I love that yeah great because there's
also an awkward Damian's in this bat
suit and it's got similar Line work
that's great I'm so sorry
Damien forgive me
he hugged his boy it is an honor to
present this boy to the court but we
must be certain of his loyalty we are
the court of ours and we require more
than words your mask oh
oh no we discussed this
oh Bruce Wayne's Ward
how do you that means weighingess
Batman no you're wrong
oh that's very bad oh not good imagine
how deeply we can hurt the Batman by
killing this boy no he's supposed to
take my place in the ritual oh you're
gonna make him goop True Colors Now kill
him
yes grand master
I like that that little mask really had
them fold yeah I mean it's very hard to
tell I know this is the glasses
disguised universe and all that stuff oh
how self-identity a lot of Reflections
in this movie talent's heart grows three
sizes today there it is make a choice
yeah
oh sweet
run
because that takes care of the secret
identity problem Yep they're all gone
here Sally
God
oh that boy and me dad my darling forget
that the two of us can
two of us wow that's why it's dead
I thought that's what they were implying
but I wasn't sure
yep
Bruce Wayne is a complication
he has to be dealt with Wowie
oh yeah
oh boy you'll be safe here till I'm done
who says I'm alone I got my goo boys
yeah
oh goody
is this like Lazarus juice I feel like
it must have some mytho sharing right
like rejuvenative all those things I
don't remember it having that in the
comic books like that tie-in grid up and
active unless someone shut it down and
didn't bother to tell us
most unkinds
cool yeah 360 team upshot do it
whoa
No Holds Barred Bruce nope
put on the bathroom
[Laughter]
they need you
throw some saucers the classic one with
the yellow chest Alfred
Alfred mech suit is he gonna do a thing
I was kidding get him outfit
the owl killer it's a big cats
oh wow
my body hurts yeah you set this one out
no I mean you're not
just line this clock you used him
manipulated him if I did you're the one
who made it so damn easy but not as easy
as this is going to be Rachel ghoul made
it this easy yeah
apparently ninjas run that way remember
that shot I didn't know that was a thing
yeah learned that in the comments I
guess it must just be more aerodynamic
or efficient or something less energy
use I don't know
smart
well done
you know truly a Father's son Damien yes
it's only gonna be a little goopy
thank you
Nightwing not a fan of stairs we've
learned nope two different times opted
out I've received some pertinent
information from Master open the damn
door
cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was the year Batman was invented it
was a true Easter egg really I like that
come on Gundam bats
no I'm only gonna see yes
yes
sons of batches oh Jesus Alfred with the
pump yeah just taking them out
oh they've waited for this moment this
is so cool so prepared yes yes back to
back with Alfred
I want a story that's just this oh man
just smacking down else Batman and pump
Alfred oh dude MI6 training is coming
through right now
[Music]
what a g what with the tails
yeah this is among my favorite sequences
of any DC anything worth doing the work
The Joker card oh more holes
he hadn't been stabbed yet shoulders
oh
you on the court try to take control of
my city and destroy my home you messed
with my kid that this is gonna hurt and
I'm gonna enjoy it yes let it out bats
all that lack of therapy coming out
he's gonna be so chill for the next few
months
[Music]
crunchy
oh is that adrenaline
oh ooh boots to the face
ah
[Music]
with the sigh
let him go let him die like you let your
father die
stupid boy yeah he has to Die the winged
Fortune will be ours the owls they'll
never find us tell him goodbye Damien
you've got this D everything I've done
was for you and this is how you repay me
then so be it I mean everything you've
done in the past few days also you were
gonna turn him into goop yeah look at me
Damien it's all for you you could never
replace Batman he's my father yeah
it's like a reverse Star Wars
don't doubt your instincts
do a barrel roll
oh
what a conflicting little monkey what a
[Music]
I'm proud of you
oh
you tally a race you're all in here
but where am I huh this is a monastery
in the Himalayas and the monks helped me
in ways that proved to be very I don't
need any help maybe I will later on
oh yeah a lot of little turtle next to
peck so many
he needs this time to find his own place
in the world he's a 10 year old boy
there's not another child on earth like
Damian Wayne that win wears a low-cut
collar to distinguish himself sometimes
Alfred
you have to have a little faith it's
beautiful
yeah golo Damian find yourself my guy
[Music]
sometimes you gotta go on a walkabout
a walk that was cool a walk of bat a
walk a walk a bat that was cool oh it
was written by uh jmd Matthias who's
like a giant comic writer that's cool
that's why it felt like dick that's rad
yeah absolutely wrote a lot of uh
Spider-Man back Jeremy that's who that
was it was driving me crazy how I was I
knew I knew that voice yeah damn so this
has like real Comics yeah
a figure in the in the comic game that's
wicked okay that was very good uh all
right we're gonna see if there's a post
credit scene but I gotta pee before we
dive into it is there not okay we'll cut
there wait let's do this let's do the
cast yeah yeah Troy Baker's back yep
okay and Kevin Conroe is Thomas Wayne oh
that's you know what's funny I literally
had a thought where it'd be interesting
if if he oh ow weirdo
oh that's amazing I'm so happy right oh
I love that so much I know that man's
voice that is delightful that is so
funny also I love the way they use the
focus here yeah I thought it'd be funny
if Kevin Conroe voiced Talon as a
metaphor for that parallel but then
making him Thomas Wayne is interesting
in its own way yeah oh man I'll be back
audience go a few moments later oh so uh
I think amongst the favorites that was a
blast yeah that's probably my top like
three or four and we've had some like I
think overall very positive only only
like one or two were a dip but like this
was still this was up there like this
was a highlight one yeah yeah this has
been a really fun Journey as a as in
total because it's like we started out
with red hood we and then we went
straight to Flashpoint and there was
like such a high bar yeah and then yeah
and then we went to the next couple and
like there yeah and yeah I feel like we
we enjoyed them but we were like okay
but there were things that I I didn't
like just absolutely love as much and
then these past couple have been like
really super solid like especially like
Arkham uh assaulted Arkham is like an
all-time favorite animated film yeah
yeah yeah this I mean I it's funny you
know because of all the uh you know
there's been a heavy amount of debate I
feel like about Damien Wayne and Batman
and stuff like that in a recent memory
because of the James gun announcement
and everything and so this from my
perspective has been cool because you
know we're gonna get Damien coming up so
this is good primer for that but also
you know like
I get the sense Damien can be a sort of
contentious character I get the sense
that people can kind of look at Damien
like you might look at Scrappy do or
something right right you know like and
I feel like it's really easy to make a
character like that frustrating or or
annoying in a way that doesn't serve you
know the overall point and here I
thought they they did a really nice job
of keeping him consistent with the
previous movie uh but also you know just
exploring you know the the the teetering
of the philosophy and and his soul and
and you know where he's gonna fall in
terms of how he you know confronts crime
and Justice and Vengeance and all those
things and they do it very exposition to
heavy but it doesn't feel heavy-handed
here like the owls are very like it's a
philosophical distinction which is one
of the things I love about Batman so
utilizing Damian Wayne who is a very
hard character to write because he is
unlikable in a lot of ways but like
there's there has to be like this
beautiful core to all of his messiness
like the reason he's like that is the
damage but that's the reason Batman's
like that so it's cool to have that the
owls be damaged a different way and the
philosophical distinctions of how they
see solving the problem of Gotham yeah
yeah absolutely and I think they they
just have done like a nice job of of
making you understand
like Damien's conflict from all sides
and I think the court of house is a
great way to extrapolate that because
they are so convincing and they do seem
like in certain lights as if they could
be like the very close other side of the
coin from Batman where it's like the
same goal but with yeah slightly more
Cutthroat means which obviously appealed
to Damien and I thought the way they
drew that conflict of just him that
whole thing where he's like oh I've got
all these people in my head that I don't
know who to be and I'm like that's great
because you know before he even says
that you're like I'm getting this
feeling and then when he confronts that
head-on you're like yeah I feel for you
because even though yeah like you are a
bit much sometimes I get why you know I
think honestly everyone that argues uh
you know that that lovely group on the
internet's whether it's like Batman kill
it's such a weak idea to have it's so
outdated to have him not kill look at
the world we're living in this is my
point that is the point of the character
but Gotham is worse than the world
living in always and like these stories
are illustrating why Batman can't kill
because then there is nothing his whole
thing is that's the thing that separates
him from the people he's warring against
yeah these movies show that so clearly
and so beautifully because they're
nuanced because they're interesting like
this movie I love the pace I love the
way it took itself seriously but it was
still fun I love that it was a slightly
lighter Bruce because of how dark Damien
was which what I said when they
announced Damien like that's how we're
gonna get a different take on Bruce I
honestly think this is a great example
of what's going to work for the patents
and versus uh mainstream DCU and why we
need those Batmans to be distinguished
in different but sure it's funny because
that's also I think owl's live action
would better suit Pattinson sure yeah
that's even this story so it's
interesting like this is a great middle
ground but it shows the strengths of
them being separate yeah 100 and I mean
like they just the way they they utilize
all the different elements like it's so
very focused on Bruce and Damien but it
also feels like even just Nightwing MVP
every time he's just so happy he's just
always like I love the function he
serves because he does just show up to
support like what's going on yeah
usually whatever Bruce needs but like it
really feels like between him and Alfred
and now Bruce and Damien there is like a
bat family yeah that feels very alive
and vital through these animated movies
and he's like big brother to Damien and
it's it's Sun like figure but it's a
different Dynamic of sons which I really
enjoy like the older son but he's not
quite sun and I really like that
utilized here in a really unique way
because a Nightwing in the comics right
now is doing really interesting stuff
it's one of the best Nightwing runs I've
ever read like it's one of the best
night ones I think period where uh
Alfred was killed and he inherits uh
basically you find out that Alfred had a
large chunk of the Wayne money and so
Nightwing gets all that money so okay
Bruce had never put money into the city
he used its weren't criminals whereas
Nightwing literally starts putting money
into bloodhaven and shows that great
what if Batman used the money for
literally putting into the city so
Nightwing is putting money into the city
that he's trying to save and it's this
beautiful dichotomy of the world view of
Batman and Nightwing but in that
Nightwing is both a public figure as
Dick Grayson and as Nightwing because
it's Dick Grayson that's putting the
money out there so it's a really cool
storyline that shows the difference
between them but it is also something
that we see paternal Bruce Wayne in a
different way because he's proud of dick
for making the choice he never did or
could and he sees that he was raised
less uh tormented because he sees that
he's a good father because the dick is
able to do that but he sees the altruism
so it's a genius like it's actually a
great Batman book with Batman barely in
it uh Art Is by Bruno Redondo it's
stunning uh written by Tom Taylor highly
recommend you all check it out but
watching things like this and seeing
Nightwing it's really beautiful to see
how that could play in live action and
how the comic book is a different take
and all these mediums have different
strengths yeah absolutely and I mean
this this was cool because this
effortlessly felt like part of this DC
AMU Journey we've been going on yeah but
parts of it reminded me of like the vibe
and flavor of the animated series and
then you have the more adult you know
kind of modern sensibility in that you
know I mean this would be a hard PG-13
yeah yeah yeah so you know like it's not
for kids necessarily but I think they
they tow that line in a way that works
and I think that like you said is
complemented really well by paternal
Bruce which I really like because you
know every you know parents in general
especially from a kid's perspective like
there is like a weird disconnect always
who you are as mom or dad and then who
you are is like you know the your own
individual out in the world and so you
multiply that by by being Batman and you
can see that from multiple perspectives
and I like that for Bruce because it's I
like seeing that side of him he's a bit
older he's a bit more mature he has yeah
like you can see the goodness in this
guy and where he chooses to put it but
at the same time when he's out and he's
dealing with the court of owls and
especially when you've got the like
their uh you know zombified henchmen
yeah he's just cooking those fools and
you could tell he's still got like it
doesn't water down the cool [__] about
Batman or the brooding nature of the
character even though yeah there is a
bit more Dimension and stuff like that
and having Bruce get his screen time in
that way doesn't diminish Batman which
is what you're saying and I really like
seeing that Bruce and I also think
that's gonna be the difference in the
two universes is Matt Reeves Batman
doesn't have a Bruce Wayne yet he hasn't
developed that character in Canon and
also in the movie but we can have that
with an older Bruce and we can have you
know a Bruce that's more developed and
that's gonna be really exciting yeah
cause you know like the more times you
check in with Batman the more you you
need to feel I think like he just is
alive and is a person yeah like
something to look to yeah so yeah I mean
I really love this one definitely a
highlight for me I'm excited for what's
next uh this was a blast I felt every
one of those into Nightwing that was
brutal uh so much violence in this one
great action great tone great paranoid
like conspiracy like it had all those it
had the action but it also had add that
like detective Noir something under the
city something's wrong here like owls
wide shut you said it but it's genius I
really enjoyed the alphabet shot
underbelly it was real good yes uh I
thought they captured a lot of the
things I love about that story I thought
Talon was very menacing and interesting
I thought the parallels were there uh
but yeah if you guys uh want to leave a
comment below let us know what your
favorite part of Batman vs Superman is
uh let us know which of these you enjoy
the most just let's start a conversation
I want to hear from y'all and we're
gonna keep going through the dcau
technically all the DC animated film
it's gonna be okay we're gonna find out
what's next when you guys do it's gonna
sit in this chair see what happens it's
gonna be exciting but please do like
subscribe share notification Bell tell
your friends and if you want to watch
this whole thing you want to see the
moments that didn't make this on the
YouTube check out super sexy patronage
to see it lined up one to one because
there's a lot of moments that uh we're
gasping I think I gasped more than this
one then yeah it was a lot more like
GoPhone it was a lot more like oh I got
a wrapped right now I'm almost
forgetting myself yeah
were moments that I was like yeah so
this was great really enjoyed this one
this is a favorite for me uh again let
us know what your favorites are and we
will see you very soon rejects much love